طبعا المنافسه على افريقيا لا يمكن ان تظل
موسكو خارجها ايضا فتعميقه العلاقات في
القارات السمراء اصبح اولويه ملحه بالنسبه
لكريملين ولكن نظرا لانها لا تستطيع
التنافس في التجاره والاستثمار فان
تكتيكاتها تهدف في المقام الاول الى تقويض
وتعطيل نفوذ الغرب وتوقيع صفقات اسلحه
كينيا التي تعتبر اكثر المنتقدين الافارقه
للحرب في اوكرانيا وصوتت في الامم المتحده
لادانه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه استقبلت
لافروف في زياره مفاجئه موسكو لديها
طموحات لقاعده بحريه في المنطقه مع الوصول
الى قناه السويس والمحيط الهندي ما يجعل
التقارب مع كينيا ضروره رئيس بوتين يستعد
لاستضافه القاده الافارقه في وقت لاحقا من
هذه السنه وهي القمه الثانيه منذ عام 2019
والتي اشتذبت 43 رئيس دوله الى سوتشي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقاري ر
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات